MARTIN: Hey, [? Meta. ?] I heard
you built a cool application
recently.
SPEAKER: Hi, Martin.
Yes, my colleague Guillaume
and I built a serverless app.
It has multiple [INAUDIBLE]
services communicating
in a nice choreography.
MARTIN: Choreography?
Can you explain that a little?
SPEAKER: Sure.
When you have a set of
[INAUDIBLE] services,
how do you get those
[INAUDIBLE] services
to interact with each
other toward a common goal?
There are two approaches,
choreography and orchestration.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In choreography, each
service works independently
and interacts with other
services in a loosely coupled
way through events.
In orchestration, there
is a central orchestrator
controlling all interactions
between services.
In our app called
[? Picadaily, ?] we
decided to go with choreography.
MARTIN: [? Picadaily, ?]
what does that mean?
SPEAKER: Good question.
It's a picture-sharing app.
We built it as a prototype
for a customer in London.
We combined Picadilly
Circus from London
with picture sharing and decided
to call it [? Picadaily. ?]
MARTIN: Oh, cool.
Can I see a demo, [INAUDIBLE]?
SPEAKER: Of course.
Let's take a look.
I already have some pictures
uploaded in the app.
Under each picture, you
can see some labels.
These are labels extracted
by Vision API telling us
what the picture is about.
Around each picture, you can
also see a colored border.
This is the dominant color of
the picture, again extracted
by the Vision API.
The app also creates a collage
of four most recent pictures.
And you can see that
under the Collage tab.
MARTIN: Oh, nice app.
So can you tell us what's
happening behind the scenes
and how you used this
choreography pattern?
SPEAKER: Let's look at
that architecture diagram.
First, users upload pictures
to a Cloud Storage bucket
using an App Engine frontend.
That triggers an event
to a cloud function.
This cloud function
uses Vision API
to extract labels and
colors of the image
and saves them to
Cloud Firestore.
The same event triggers
a Cloud Run service
that creates a
thumbnail of the image.
There is a second
Cloud Run service
that gets triggered
by Cloud Scheduler
to create a collage of
four most-recent pictures
on a schedule.
Finally, a third
Cloud Run service
gets triggered by
deletion events.
It does some cleanup
after an image is deleted.
We are using built-in
events for cloud functions
and Event [INAUDIBLE]
for Cloud Run.
The whole architecture
is event driven,
also known as choreography.
MARTIN: I see.
So what are the pros and
cons of choreography?
SPEAKER: Yeah, in choreography,
services are loosely coupled.
And because they
are loosely coupled,
they can be changed and
scaled independently.
If a service fails, the
rest of the services
can still send and
receive events,
so there is no single
point of failure.
And if you want to
add a new service
or remove an existing
service to a new domain,
eventing makes that really easy.
MARTIN: All right, so
then how do you monitor
event-driven systems like this?
SPEAKER: Well, with all
the events flying around,
it's actually quite hard to
monitor event-driven systems.
It's also not so easy to catch
errors or apply global error
and retry policies.
MARTIN: Mmm, I see.
And where is the
business logic captured?
SPEAKER: Business logic
ends up being a side
effect of the architecture.
It's spread out to each service.
And there is no single central
place that you can point to.
MARTIN: Got it.
So can we fix
these cons somehow?
SPEAKER: Yes, we can.
Need to keep the
loosely coupled nature
of event-driven services,
but also bring some structure
in the flow of events.
We need some kind
of an orchestrator.
Check out the next
episode for details.
MARTIN: Cool,
Thanks, [INAUDIBLE]..
And thank you,
everyone, for watching.
If you want to build
this app, there
is a hands-on workshop
with a series of labs.
The code is open source
on GitHub as well.
All the links are
in the show notes.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]